one two three hi we're doing gruff and
your watch ad though you are watching
the wired automatically interview great
job I don't know that we could have
landed that better I feel like I've
never looked better
let's shoot this bad boy so number one
who Jonathan Groff well how would you
answer this question who Jonathan Groff
meet Jonathan Groff mm-hmm okay who does
Jonathan Groff look like uh-oh people
type that in it yeah number clearly the
number two most googled question about
you okay I think you look like a real
piece of who do you look like I mean you
you have a very unique look I would say
agree I think I look pretty generic no
you you are a very handsome individual
well thank you I should know because I
am also incredibly handsome and so I
keep company with others who look like
me in fact I would say the answer to
this question is John looks like Josh
definitely clearly who is jonathan groff
in Hamilton I don't know I know this as
you saw it I saw it four times
you were Aaron Burr the one who sings
I'm Aaron Burr yeah that serves me the
king who ever had to google this I'm
angry at because this isn't a question
that you need to ask Google it's a
question that you ask God because that's
how good Jonathan was in that show how
dare you
who is jonathan groff thought that his
mom is mom who's Jonathan Groff is mom
her name is Julie mm-hmm she is my mom
mm-hmm she saw frozen this year on her
bro she saw frozen too on her birthday
14 oh she said it was the best birthday
she ever had
sure I saw the video of your mom I sent
you a video that came out like like a
your mom joke and it wasn't meant to I
saw a video of
you're literally literally because you
sent it yeah who did jonathan groff who
did jonathan groff play on One Life to
Live I played one life to live like the
soap opera
oh wow when were you on One Life to Live
it was during Spring Awakening
I remember this you know so was that fun
it was it was not fun in that you had to
wake up so early
doing each was a weekend then waking up
early I was not a fan of who does
Jonathan Groff play in frozen well I
know the answer to this because I've
been there for both films yeah Jonathan
Groff playing Kristoff and Sven do you
get two checks no I feel better about
myself today okay is Josh GAD yes always
it's Josh GAD on tinder it's just good
well that's a dick thing to ask Google
like do you expect the answers thank you
reader Josh GAD is actually a dick we've
done an investigation and Josh GAD
steals money from children like what
were you expecting this answer to be
it's Josh that a nice guy I think you
just gave them the answer I don't want
to hear from you no you are no no you're
a very nice guy be either's your voice
went up there was a hesitation yeah no
you're such a nice guy I feel like why
are you blinking these are all tells is
Josh GAD
oh he's Josh GAD in Angry Birds too
that's random from the writer of is Josh
got a nice guy
hey what do you think be very careful
think he is I think you are why would
you have to think that why wouldn't you
run out to go see Angry Birds too when
it's in theaters I know as a portly
because I saw oh yeah it came out and I
saw it oh wow yeah I knew exactly when
mine hunter came out I even tweeted
about it he's a man yeah you wouldn't
cuz you're not on Twitter I'm not I was
like oh Jonathan Groff is in the show
watch it
I wrote a Josh GAD is in Angry Birds -
you had no idea you had to ask out a
nice guy is Josh GAD married
well funny you should ask that question
wait a second I'm like looking for the
tell-tale oh it's because you and I are
together today usually I would wear it
but I don't want to give you the
impression that I'm not available you
know what you know what it is what it's
that my finger is so fat right now that
I can't get the damn ring on no no
that's not true I was setting such a bad
an interview without my wedding ring I
am married happily with two children
thank you so much for asking
is Josh cash into topia that's
definitely no no I mean right I don't
think you topia know I'm not in Zootopia
at least to the best of my knowledge
here we go where does jonathan groff
live another creepy question that's the
kind of question that leads to robberies
why setting people ask that because they
want to hunt you so do you want to tell
them where you live where should I live
in New York I have give them an address
clearly they want more information
they're googling about it a lot I'm not
gonna do anything I always did
How I Met Your Mother Jonathan how are
those people telling you how they met
your real mom or are they looking for
the character they know it this actually
is another Jonathan gruff who is a
brilliant comedy writer producer who
also produces blackish
no way yeah have you reached out to
other Jonathan Groff we met at Hamilton
he came to see the show with his family
all right Jonathan
vocal range high idea high Alto Metso
soprano yeah I don't really I honestly
don't know my vocal range I never I
never studied sing a little
sing a low note nothing a high note you
got a great ring thank you
there's your answer Google all right
Jonathan Gras mind Hunter yeah yeah
that's all me is jonathan groff mine
under definitely yeah okay yeah we got
have we had mines by the way this guy's
brilliant on mine hunter I've never seen
it but that's what my family tells me
Jonathan gruff podcast is your jonathan
groff podcast it's just a third Jonathan
growth no I did a podcast musical called
36 questions that was based on a New
York Times article can you give us a
sample hmm 35 36 36 35 plus one yes the
answer you've been looking for
you've heard it 34 is not the end of our
story
stay tuned for two more when Josh GAD
Josh GAD first age at baby Josh GAD grow
post baby into toddler Josh GAD age past
toddler into big boy when this was
longer when Josh GAD when Josh GAD go to
high school with English stop being
taught across America I went to high
school in the 90s I graduated high
school in 99 way-hey true story when did
you graduate high school 2003
when Josh GAD Book of Mormon Josh GAD
started Book of Mormon in 2011 why are
you looking at me so provocatively right
now this is just remembering that we
shared the same dressing room when
Jonathan Groff is a John at the AG no
Neil you're in the same dressing room
that's right I'm sorry wakening yep and
I remember going to see Josh dad in the
Book of Mormon and feeling like I'd
never seen such an iconic comedic
performance in a musical on stage in my
life I love can we do a Broadway show
together one Josh GAD and Jonathan got
to Broadway together he's one of you
right away I've ever seen I don't want
to hear it because Spring Awakening
when Josh Gaston sung so we're stopping
English in general this is a new
language are we talking about in the
movie what like at what point I think
it's an hour ten into the white cab I
don't understand here was it yeah one
when Josh GAD when Josh GAD gets a song
why would say it means when Josh GAD
Gaston song because in that movie cuz
that's all I want to go back and watch
all right so what point in the movie
Beauty and the Beast is the Gaston song
because I want to rewatch right once
Gaston song midway through beauty and
beast when did Josh GAD lose his
virginity oh I wonder Josh GAD grow up
Josh GAD is always in a steady state of
growing up as you can probably tell by
this interview Josh GAD has yet to fully
grow up there it is
mm-hmm Josh GAD always child at heart
Josh GAD wannabe lost boy Josh GAD never
want to grow just can't want to live for
F wired hot oh my gosh guys